what is a country still synonymous with
football do to get its yellow color away
from right-wing politics I'm talking
about Brazil where the recent election
was a close call and Lula won just a
little over 50 percent of the vote now
there is a similar division over the
country's iconic yellow Jersey it's both
a symbol of the country's dominance over
the sport and it's also worn by the
supporters of right-wing outgoing
president bolsonaro they wear it to
rallies and they wear it to protest the
new left-wing president-elect ahead of
this year's World Cup Brazil's Football
Association is trying to watch politics
from the famous shirt they launched a
video campaign and in a rap song players
over cheering fans all dressed in yellow
the lyrics of which translate to Let's
love her and let's go yellow many are
skeptical though they can Bridge The
Divide over the color Sports pundits
tell me the use of Brazil's national
colors dates back to Brazil's military
dictatorship which ended in 1985. under
bolsonaro though the Embrace of the
yellow Jersey was taken to a new level
so many fans don't want to wear it
anymore Street Hawkers and Rio de
Janeiro even tell me they're selling
more blue shirts these days
[Music]